[Music]
so much stuff happened this year it's
like day the the best day of 2016 is the
time my birthday you know we woke up I
played basketball in case you didn't
know I'm a national champion so this
ball back here I was somebody out ball
his life but anyway my birthday
we woke up picked up a bunch of food
brought it to salvation on me then left
there had a huge dinner bunch more
friends came and we jammed all night and
it was a beautiful creative explosion of
love and joy and that was hospitalized
vert day the ties between met and when I
played the national anthem with Stevie
Wonder on the day before election day
just harmonica and home on the boy I
started playing the harmonica or
partially because of Stevie Wonder full
circle to be on stage playing with one
of the guys that inspired me to play the
instrument playing a song that was so
important for our culture in our
mythology deep the best destination this
year definitely was Montreux Switzerland
and there's the Montreux Jazz Fest but I
wasn't performing I went out just to go
into the mountains and I was hanging out
there with Quincy Jones who was a mentor
of mine and it's amazing I that was a
good time
the best outfit this year what I wore on
the performance that I did of Blackbird
which was the anniversary of the Beatles
coming to America and performing on The
Ed Sullivan Show and I wore this black
suit that was something that was
designed specifically for the
performance very understated and subtle
but the combination of the fit and the
occasion and in the way that it it kind
of his elegant but with an edge I like
that one
the best meal I had in 2016 was my mom's
red beans and rice as always every year
is the best meal no offense to the great
restaurants in my city but when you go
to somebody's house and you will really
want red beans or rice a gumbo jambalaya
crawfish get it from somebody's house
somebody's grandmother's house goodness
so yeah my mom that's it